I rewatched the last video two weeks
later and hated it usually when i
rewatch a video there's a hundred little
things i dislike but this was probably
the worst it went a bit too fast for me
even though i wrote it and was pretty
boring in this video I'm going to try
make after it by re explaining some
things people found confusing and
answered the homework first I want to re
explain the essential idea of the last
video in a more compact and abstract way
I think it might make it easier feel
free to skip this though if you had your
wave function in terms of some variable
X then if you measured X you just use
the born rule to find out the
probability of each of these states this
doesn't show any interference between
these states in other words it looks
just like the particle within one of
those states all along and we just
didn't know which however this isn't
really the case and we can tell if we
measure another thing let's call it Y we
can tell because of this if we had a
particle that really was in state x1 or
really a bunch of particles in that
state and we measure Y we can find out
the probability that we measure it in
state y1 or y2 etc then we can do the
same thing with particles in state x2
etc but our original particle was in a
superposition state so if I really
thought that it was in just one of these
states with probabilities from the
coefficients I'd write it like this now
you can use your high school probability
theory to work out what the
probabilities are when you measure Y so
how about pause the video and work out
the probability that the particle will
be in state y1 when measured also what
does quantum mechanics predict so the
answer is you add up the probabilities
of each of these branches and so you get
this however this is not what you get if
you really did the experiment and it's
not what quantum mechanics predicts
that's because in quantum mechanics the
particle really is in a
superposition of all of these at the
same time and so each of these interfere
with each other
giving you a different result okay so
now we're ready to answer the first
homework question explain how this
interference is the same thing as the
interference in the double slit
experiment there are a few ways you can
answer this all valid but in particular
I want to show why the interference in
both cases is the same thing from a
completely mathematical standpoint what
is observable X in the double slit
experiment this might surprise you but
it's which door the particle goes
through you may be thinking that that's
not an observable but it is because
remember you can measure it by putting
detectives at the doors a particle is in
a superposition of all possible X values
it could have in this case it's a
superposition of going through door 1
and 2 if I measure which door there is
no interference it just looks like the
particle really was just going through
one door but we know that that isn't the
case and we can show it by measuring
something else instead the observable
way is where the particle lands on the
far wall we know that if the particle
goes through one door it lands somewhere
behind that door so if we believe that
it really only went through one door but
we just didn't know which we'd expect
two blobs behind each door of course
that's not what we get in other words we
got interference well that was probably
boring as hell but I really wanted to
spell out that connection
hopefully you're interested in why the
interference pattern looks like that
that's something I'll explain in a video
soon for that you need to convert the
wave function from X to Y in this case
from being in terms of which slit to
what position it lands that's very
closely related to how you go from wave
function in terms of position to one in
terms of speed or momentum by the way
can I introduce a piece of jargon here
we call this process a change of basis
here it's changing from the position
basis to the momentum
if a wave function is written let's say
in terms of spin up and down we say it's
written in the spin up-down basis
remember we can write the wave function
in any basis we want we can tell a wave
function is written in a particular
basis if these states are eigenstates of
that observable remember eigenstate is a
term I briefly mentioned last time
rather quickly what it means is if I
measure say position an eigenstate of
position is a particular position or if
I measure spin up/down this I can only
get up or down so each of these are
eigenstates so for any observable X and
eigenstate is a possible value you can
get when you measure that observable
really there is no need for this term
but it makes physicists happy so
sometimes I'll use it getting back to
the homework the next question was what
has any of this got to do with the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle so
here's my chance to use the term
eigenstate a lot say a particle is an
eigenstate of an observable X in other
words it really is just in one X state
if X was positioned that would mean it
really is just in one place no matter
how many times you measure it it will
still be there so you have no
uncertainty about its x value but now we
want to know the uncertainty we have
about some other variable Y let's say
speed or momentum how can we find out we
change basis we rewrite this X
eigenstate into a y1 now say it looks
like this this means that if I measure Y
there are all these values it can be and
so there is an uncertainty about my
value of y and so it's not possible to
have no uncertainty about x and y for
the same particle later on we'll go
further and find that often if there's a
little uncertainty about X there has to
be a fair bit of uncertainty about Y and
vice versa next question this one was
about hidden variables does this
interference stuff mean that hidden
variables are impulse
spoole the answer is no and let me take
the double-slit experiment as an example
of why not
remember hidden variable theories want
to say a particle really does only do
one thing at a time and isn't in a
superposition they can do this if
they're clever about it the particle can
go through just one door but it has to
know that the other door is open and it
has to change its behavior accordingly
something like bohmian mechanics does
just that and you can prove
mathematically that that theory will
give you exactly the same results as
quantum mechanics but you see both
theories are really weird bohmian
mechanics is by no means classical okay
so homework is over and this is already
way longer than I'd like but I figure
you'll leave if you're bored the last
thing I want to do is a request to redo
a calculation from the last video
remember I asked you what would happen
if I measure this particle a
superposition of up and down in terms of
left and right instead by the way I've
decided that I'll explain what spin up
and down and everything means physically
in the next video because that was
requested a lot anyway in case you're
interested this is how people answered
the question to start we need to
remember how to convert from up/down
agon States to left right so far I've
just stated this as a rule it says
whenever you see up you can change basis
by replacing it with right plus left and
whenever you see down you can replace it
with a right minus left so in our case
we have this and so we change basis by
replacing this up and down all that's
left at this point is expanding these
brackets and then collecting terms these
two right eigen states are constructive
the left eigen states are opposite signs
and so they're destructive in the end we
just get that up plus down equals right
I encourage you to try up- down and you
should get left ok so here's the cool
thing we know how to change basis from
up/down to
right but now we can change bases the
other way if I have a state like this in
the left/right basis I can now use the
previous result and replace that left
and right
this video was actually okay to make I
managed to write the script in about
four hours instead of four straight days
of agony I think I'll try to do this
more often